[Música]
olá você mãe você pai você é jovem não
peça desculpas por não pretende
atrapalhar o bom andamento do evento
afinal deveriam estar no ônibus lotado
mas estamos aqui no edifício ana carina
oliveira tenho 26 anos só de andar ou
candle horas uma empresa que trabalha
com educação para que empreende por
necessidade
ela deve estar se perguntando por que
diabos em trabalhar com quem empreende
por necessidade
a simples se você anda de ônibus ou
trabalha em bairros comerciais você
consegue nem tem percebido o grande
aumento no número de pessoas que a gente
chama de ambulante ou aquela pessoa que
faz um corre ou aquela pessoa que faz um
bico mas isso é uma coisa que já tem
muito tempo por exemplo o desemprego
estrutural na inclusive trabalhando com
dados do sebrae soma 17 milhões de
pessoas desempregados e para além disso
outro dado que é muito interessante é
entender que quem empreende por
necessidade tem exatamente essa cara são
a maioria mulheres jovens e de bairros
periféricos e quando fala sobre
empreender por necessidade é aquela
pessoa que não tenha outra fonte de
renda e que só decidiu empreender por
subsistência mas a gente não veio falar
sobre isso hoje eu quero mostrar pra
vocês
o quanto isso também pode ser um
potencial e que está presente muitas
vezes nossas vidas fazendo isso queria
trazer uma história da copa é de que ela
já é velho da federação onde 2002 nessas
cinco mulheres nem era uma grande
oportunidade de negócio onde foi abrir
uma lanchonete na universidade
particular
mas qual é o problema exatamente esse
elas tiveram que ganhar funcionante e
arranjar todo o resto ou seja
equipamentos insumos e elas começaram
exatamente com uma geladeira que
demorava cinco horas fechado para
começar a gelar um fogão de quatro bocas
que só pega 12 e algumas panelas que por
fora estava complicada mas que por
dentro dá até pra lã e r$50 de capital
de giro importante então a única coisa
que elas conseguiriam fazer a milho
cozido cachorro quem salada de fruta
daqui uma semana era milho cozido
de fruta e cachorro-quente imagine daqui
um mês essa coisa não tinha mudado ainda
era menino cozido só de fruta e cachorro
quente se você está enjoado dessas
coisas e imagem daqueles alunos que
estavam lá mas mesmo sem formação mesmo
sem saber o que estavam fazendo
elas tiveram a oportunidade que afinal
de contas na semana de prova
ficar todo mundo desesperado pra cama
ansiedade e através disso elas começaram
a perceber que se você decidiu acaso 20
reais em compras
ela te dá um vídeo é de crédito e usa
terá a semana inteira pra comprar lanche
do quanto vocês quiserem para aqueles 20
reais para a partir disso dá para
diversificar a produção e conquistar
mais coisas
aquelas mulheres não sabiam qual era o
nome disso mas o que criatividade
digital usando da mesma forma uma outra
coisa que eu queria falar pra vocês é
que eu entendo que pedia elevador é
massa mas já pensar no desafio do
pitbull
sim exatamente isso eu desafio vocês a
entrar no ônibus lotado tendo apenas um
ponto ao outro e sem estrutura
conquistar aquelas pessoas para que elas
se invista num negócio assim existem
várias pessoas que ganham a vida fazendo
exatamente isso
então pare pense nós temos exemplos na
nossa comunidade e são pessoas que só
fazem porque aquele empreendimento tem
que dar certo todos os dias eles não têm
outra opção porque afinal de contas o
fracaso é o fracaso muitas vezes de uma
família inteira então vocês também já
passaram por isso todo mundo que tá
ouvindo inclusive você aquele aquele
obstáculo que você passou e que você
falou que não ia dar não ia ter tempo
nem a estrutura foi super extração de
passar por aquilo mas afinal de contas
você aqui
quantas vezes aconteceu durante esse ano
e se te perguntar se você faria você
dizia que não mas de pode só ter que
fazer
olha o que você aprendeu é exatamente
sobre isso que a gente está falando
então na próxima vez que você observar
esses empreendimentos não esqueçam que
estão levando ali o propósito e
sobreviverem todos os dias e que isso é
muito importante que a gente pensa que
por isso que eles cometem alguns erros
mas quem disse que eu ensinei essa
galera empreender
se eles fazem negócio dar certo todos os
dias estão vindo lá de uma cambada
este ensinamento que é muito importante
e que ele diz assim que lá na savana a
gazela corda mas ela não acorda por
acordar ela acorda com um único objetivo
correr o mais rápido possível porque o
objetivo dela sobreviver diante mão o
leão ele também acorda e não só a cola
por acordar mas ele também acorda com um
único objetivo de correr do que é mais
lenta a gazela porque afinal de contas
ele tem um objetivo que também se
alimentar para sobreviver então pouco me
importa se nessa brincadeira você gazé
lowell a ideia que sempre quando você
acordar
nunca pare de correr até quando nossos
objetivos
você então elas a mãe que precisa agora
luti
[Aplausos]
[Música]